saying that men and women are equal is
evil because there is a natural
hierarchy of things it is supposed to go
God men women children that is the
natural hierarchy so feminism is and
always has been a hate group it has
always been give me special treatment as
women without the responsibility that
comes with it okay so this whole idea is
like that there were waves of feminism
and the first one was good it was never
good they were known for planning
assassinations they were not
particularly liked by most women first
wave feminism the majority of women
didn't want to vote because it came with
being drafted
um and now basically they wanted to give
us special privileges without the
responsibility that comes with it